christina how are you wait a minute what
is that poster in the back
on this side yeah it's depeche mode
all right all right
listen man i was in college when depeche
mode started so i'm a
peshmerga fan i'm a big music person so
that's all right
first of all thank you for making a show
about wrestling that even i as someone
who
only knows the absolute bare minimum can
enjoy
i love that we love that christina
that's the best news that we could hear
i feel like genre doesn't matter if you
tell a great story with great characters
in a full world
so thank you well you're you're you
getting the word out about that so
people aren't just terrified and think
to themselves
this show isn't for me is the most
important thing
michael i'm curious i mean you currently
seem like the guy with the golden touch
you've gone from assistant on community
to head writer on loki a writer on dr
strange you're doing a star wars project
you're creating this show
what most blows your mind from where you
started out
to now we well yeah i mean i'm very
very fortunate uh
yeah i guess that i'm having to do all
my interviews over
zoom that's why it doesn't feel real i
still feel like i'm just in college
because it's all you you hit it big
during covet it's kind of just
uh no i mean you know what
what blows my mind is the people i get
to collaborate with
and that that's that's that might sound
like hot air
[ __ ] but it but it's true like and
that that's that's the dream come true
for me
is i'm still relatively
young and new in my career and i'm
getting to work with people with so much
experience
and so everything for me is still i'm
still learning
um and so you know whether that's
working with sam rainey
on dr strange you know or
it's like mike's a great example of that
uh on
on heels and he came on as the show
runner
um of heels when we when we kind of
brought it back to life
uh when i was midway through
you know i guess on the whole loki
process and i learned a lot from him
you know and it was great to suddenly
have
a new friend who had been a show runner
before and
and who had his own wealth of experience
and everything and that
that helped me so i i just feel
fortunate with the folks that i get to
collaborate with for real because it
makes
it makes me look better and it actually
makes me better
mike you've been amassing producing and
writing credits
but you're primarily known to audiences
as an actor and you're still
acting in this show what made you want
to
run the show and what are you enjoying
about being a showrunner that
you don't get from acting well
you know as you can see from michael's
answer he's a very generous guy
who's had just a meteoric
and deserved rise to
success because he works really really
hard
there's a lot of jack spade and michael
waldron none of the bad qualities
no but but he works really really hard
and he really really cares
and so yes i have been doing this for a
long time and i'm like everyone else i
wake up and when one job ends i don't
know what the next job is
and i um you know i started out
writing plays because i wasn't
necessarily getting i wanted something
to do with the energy the creative
energy that i had
and the idea that when you're an actor
all you have is your face
and and you know you have your ability
but that
you know it's not necessarily enough to
carry your
artistic pursuits uh and and
what am i going to do with my time and i
love this
business i love storytelling and so i
started to
when my kids were just younger take on
and try to do more of the producing
writing on shameless and
creating a show for stars so when this
opportunity came up
i was just amazed at the writing in the
world that michael
had done you're always listen every day
you're an actor
you know you're waiting for your agent
to call and say i read this script
it's going to be great and then you read
it you want to be a part of it it's no
different when you're a writer or show
runner
um you know one of the reasons i got
involved in this is because i knew that
you know we had a really well
rounded world uh that was already
created
and i knew enough or i had enough
confidence in my ability to produce that
if we found the right cast
and and you know we had a great we had a
great director
directors pete siegel and jessica lowry
you know the hardest thing is the script
and then if you haven't you have the
support of a network and studio
great actors that now it's fun now it's
fun
now it literally is just it's a charge
to make it
um so you know that that for me it's
just like you know
is and then once i was the showrunner i
knew i could cast myself
i'd be like come on you guys now how far
ahead are you guys thinking
have you developed a second season are
there things you're learning from
doing a first season that could help
make a second season easier
i just want to say michael's already
figured out five years what scares me
is that then we have to actually start
typing those up
but he knows yeah i mean i
you know this this show has lived in my
head since
2013. so i've i've had a lot of time
to think about where it might go when
you know and we we've teed up with this
first season i i i
we've launched i think was it an
exciting adventure
uh in its own way and so yeah there's
that that's the great thing about doing
a show set in the world of wrestling
is it's a far-reaching um
world with populated with a lot of
different
crazy characters and with you know
a batshit crazy history and mythology
to keep pulling from so we're never
gonna be
uh wanting for source material
so to speak so so it is it's a it's a
rich world
you know that that i think yeah
there's there's a little more meat on
the bone i think there's three more
episodes coming your way christina and
five six and seven i think you're really
going to enjoy
if you enjoyed the first four and i
think that one of the things that we set
up
is as a little bit of success comes
their way
how do people how do people operate when
when they can feel like that success is
coming and i think that's what we're set
up for in the second season
is that you know there are people who
are emotionally intertwined with one
another and don't like how they're being
treated
and you know maybe you have or certainly
all of us have worked at jobs that even
though they might have been compensating
us with
with money and benefits it wasn't the
right thing because
emotionally it wasn't the right thing i
think that's what we can continue to go
at with the wrestling world
and i do think that these guys the story
that we're telling are the men and women
of this place
they are just like the band that if
their song is heard on the radio
it will take off you know michael and i
are perfect examples of
two guys he growing up in georgia i grew
up in new hampshire we wanted to be in
this business
people like what and then you go do it
you keep grinding and then suddenly you
get an opportunity to tell stories that
the whole world gets to see
that's that's these guys that we think
these men and women at the dwl
what they're capable of if they just get
the exposure
how challenging is it to have so many
great supporting characters
and not enough time to delve into all of
them as deep as i would imagine you
want to i mean are you already coming up
with spin-off ideas
that is a fantastic question i'll answer
it from an actor's perspective uh
and as a writer and michael can say this
as a showrunner because he's had a lot
of experience
doing that certainly on loki um and with
this show but
the thing about it is it you know we
talk we this happens
in the story of heels exactly what
happens on every tv show
rooster's saying i just want to push i
just want to get a chance for the title
belt
and every actor when they open up the
script
you know now some actors are like hey
man i you know i'm getting i get you
know the next four weeks off great they
still got to pay me the same amount of
money
that's not most actors they want to be
front and center they want to have
emotional material yes they're getting
paid but what they want to do
is they want to be seen they want to be
recognized they want to
they want to work and so they want more
and so it's a very perceptive question
because i was just working on a series
snow piercer where there's 25 speaking
characters in a 40-minute show
that's a lot of mouths to feed it
literally are mouths
two feet with lines and you have to be
thinking about that
all the time and so michael did a very
good job this year and
giving everyone material but
next year if you knock on wood if we
come back
that is that is foremost in you know our
mind
how do you give enough material to
everyone yeah i mean especially
the women i just i love the women on the
show and i want to see
so much more of them as well well you
got it so you
have to watch five six seven and eight
because they're so it's not going where
you think
and not to tip anything there's so
much talking and doing
that they do in these episodes that i
think you're going to be
surprised given what what what the idea
of this show is and
and then this is the situation that
michael has set up in the show that i
think is
surprising and great well thanks so much
you guys i appreciate you talking to me
about it i
absolutely will be watching the rest of
the season so thank you
all right but listen mary mccormack
allison luff
uh alice barrett mitchell and kelly
berglund
have when i say monologues
i mean pages of talking
and they get a lot more to do and
that's what i think is surprising and
interesting about how michael set up
this world
and how we delivered it well i'm looking
forward to it thank you
thanks christina